they started early after 16 years
without answers there was no time to
lose officers from Germany Portugal and
the UK searching a reservoir 30 miles
from where Madeleine McCann disappeared
the three-year-old went missing from her
hotel room in 2007.
this convicted German sex offender
Christian B has been named as the prime
suspect in the case
he denies any involvement
but this is a place he allegedly called
his paradise and after receiving a
tip-off German prosecutors ordered a new
search
I can't disclose the background at the
moment why we are searching there and
what we hope to find there that shall
remain a secret for the moment
throughout the day teams scoured the
ground hoping it would reveal any
secrets it may hold
boat teams waited on the water officers
determined to uncover any evidence that
may be hidden here
when you have a look at this Reservoir
it's absolutely massive and the idea of
being able to search it all in two days
seems like a mammoth task but from
watching the teams here they appear to
be focusing on carefully controlled
areas this search is clearly targeted
Christian B lived in the area when
Madeleine went missing from prior to
luge her disappearance sparked a huge
investigation drawing worldwide
attention
in the town near the reservoir people
still remember him Constantino describes
him as a Bohemian who he'd see wandering
around
he was here for a long time
I knew him from sight because I used to
work at prior dilouche at some of the
events
he was there when it happened
for more than a decade this tragedy has
left a shadow on the region once again
people here and across Portugal are
hoping for answers
Siobhan Robbins Sky News in Portugal